yes Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
this one's from Richard to gel in
Todmorden England in the UK said a big
fan of the show thanks so much hope I
can see you live someday I'm thinking
with Ralph's tales of old his old life
of swinging and general de Patri he may
have visited this town near me in
England on a few occasions let's take a
look good old wet wing welcome to wet
wing it welcomes careful driver yeah you
want careful drivers on wet wing wet
Wang can get slippery you know what I'm
saying right bud huh Abunda yeah you
have do you ever get wet Wang when you
were shot oh yeah - the side effect of
swinging swimmers ear I got what I got
wet Wang a doctor typically right wring
it out yeah you know a little bit now
it's dry Wang let's do it again
that's fascinated when you were in your
swinger period yes did you only swing in
Los Angeles or did you swing other place
Oh Kevin I swung I swung like across the
gun I swung everywhere put it in her
mouth and I put it in his ass and put it
in his hand and I put it on her head I
swung every it's frightfully easy to
write a song we have spent way too much
time together that our brains working
simultaneously now did you swing in more
than one stage yes where are the stage
swing in Utah yeah but that we hadn't
asked you but now I'm curious that guy
he remembers me no this is only my
second time ever in the state of Utah I
told you that we we did mark city with
Sundance for yoga hosers and then here
this trip all right so what were the
states beyond California ah Florida Oh
was it like swinging a Florida you
[ __ ] old people yeah yeah not old
Jewish people whom the earth no there
show veggie like the hey sex with my
wife just because there's snow on the
roof doesn't mean nation of fire in the
furnace what makes me laugh about that
as you probably did [ __ ] an old person
dare you sir I am an equal opportunity
swinger I'll have you know it's gonna
say when you're swinging this is just
like [ __ ] where if you're there in
for a penny in for a pound you uh yeah
wherever you click with you click with
all different kinds of people in life
right
Floridians where else Florida's like by
the way one of the swinger capitals in
the United States probably won't
surprise anyone because far as a [ __ ]
up state but tons of swingers clubs in
Florida my brother told me he lives in
Florida I was just there seeing mom and
what a month my brother lives down there
too he said there's a you know we were
trying to figure out like what where'd
mom goes after the hospital there's a
rehab center and he's like yeah there's
one that's real close to that swinger
place I was like what swinger place and
he was like you never heard about this
he's like there's a retirement community
for people 60 and older and they have
the highest rate of STDs of anywhere in
Florida that's funny
I said are you [ __ ] serious again
because they're all like you can't get
pregnant let's [ __ ] do it
Wow nobody wears anything and so they
just keep spreading it around I'm like
but they're all these like I know but
they're still [ __ ] so that gives me
hope
just a little penicillin and the next
thing I know the drip is gone
so where else Florida Nevada of course
Las Vegas every year for many years they
have the biggest swingers convention in
North America and lastly being a
convention they take over a hotel for a
weekend and it's filled with swingers
and swinger events there's just [ __ ]
[ __ ] everywhere it always ends like an
iceberg you know what's gonna happen
sure they do they Jackson Pollock that
[ __ ] everywhere it's not a ropes of it
go flying through the casino flying over
people playing slot machines Oh ducking
it while they're [ __ ] playing their
one-armed bandits was it just nothing
but non-stop sex well no they have
social events too and they've got a
cocktail party in social events like hi
hi let's [ __ ]
no there's it's more the better you
could chitchat to anybody in this
[ __ ] sick old world but if you're
gonna be a swinger to convention it just
should be like dick [ __ ] dick [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass that's like adjacent news rap
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]